period my hello very well a new relaxed
relations on your new show thank you I
hope you watch at home I remember you
when you were not of any importance at
all it came from an idea when reading :
Powell's memoirs of my American Journey
his mother moored in Jamaica a
seamstress wanted to get a better life
and she couldn't make up her mind
whether to go to Great Britain or
whether to go to the United States and
we all know now that she went to the
United States and : was born in Harlem
and I became fascinated by the idea of
what would have happened to the great
man if he'd been born in Hackney very
good so I thought would he 60 years ago
have gone to Sandhurst and become a
young leftenant would he have become a
field marshal would he have followed
peter carington
and Alec douglas-home as foreign
secretary no but 40 years later now we
have the first black woman MP a shadow
home secretary and a Muslim man as Home
Secretary I think he would have made it
so that got into my mind and I
transferred the whole thing into Russia
a 16 year old boy called Alexander just
won a scholarship to the famous language
school in Moscow and his father is a
trade union leader who is annoying the
KGB and they kill him they take his the
boy scholarship away they make him work
on the docks and his mother Elena a
tough lady decides they have to escape
and their uncle arranges it on the docks
and they go down to the docks and there
are two boxes and he says one is going
to the United States one is going to
Britain which one will you get into
and Alexander tosses a coin heads you
win I could write a book I mean
obviously they you must have concerns
like our present foreign secretary does
about the situation with Russia yes
indeed and indeed in writing the by
about the book I have to confess having
started it two years ago I did not
realize that Russia would be in the
headlines every single day so the timing
of heads you win is very strange in that
way which is why we've asked people
particularly professionals like yourself
not to reveal the ending I don't mind
the fact that I've teased the reader by
sending both boxes off and following the
life of Sasha and following the life of
Alex but I don't want anybody to know
until the end of course if you were
still in front-line politics how would
you be dealing with the present
situation with Russia I think actually
our foreign secretary and shadow foreign
secretary are handling it as best as
possible you've got to be firm you've
got to be determined it's clear that
Salisbury is an evil business and this
far circles videostream but they were
going down there to look at the hundred
and sixty-five foot spiral on the
Cathedral and it what a lovely city they
wanted to visit what a farce
I cannot believe any intelligent
Russians believes we're so stupid we'd
believe that so I think yes we've got to
be very firm you can't have Russians
coming on our land and killing people
indiscriminately no I'm with the
government and the officers nothing it
both been very firm how involved are you
with present-day politics well I'm
fascinated by it I'm 78 years old that's
very very kind
i I'm 78 years old and I look from the
outside doesn't stop the fact that I
checked people every day in the house
and fascinated still by politics but I
watch these new people running the
country
what sort of headlines are attracting
your attention at the moment for me
Jamal Khashoggi is is I mean I'm very
interested in Foreign Affairs and that
is a story where the United Kingdom
needs to get involved doesn't it I mean
we were being told about our buyer for
and sexually about red lines and red
lines as certainly as for our Saudi
Arabia's because then surely that has
gone over that red line what happened at
the Saudi consulate in Istanbul totally
you're talking about to show you totally
unforgivable
and totally unbelievable fortunately we
live in a world now where because of
television and because of communication
the truth eventually comes out he was
clearly murdered he was clearly disposed
of and that they've been caught and a
good thing too but I think we live
perhaps we always have I think we live
in a very unpleasant world I mean most
of the news you look at the I turn on
Sky News in the evening and the three
unhappy stories followed by something
perhaps quite pleasant
three more unhappy stories no I don't
think this is an easy world to live in
where are your brakes are happy or not I
remember chatting to you in the other
studio before break set and you were
voting to remain a lady Archer was
voting the American day Mary was indeed
voting to exit
I was remain I lost I find it very
simple we live in a democracy
I lost therefore get on with it get on
with brexit I certainly don't want a
second referendum what a complete waste
of time and I also think the British
people would be very annoyed with a
second referendum and say I think they'd
vote even more firmly to come out a
second time and it's so insulting for
people to say well we didn't have all
the facts you study as much as you want
to you look carefully at what you're
presented with you made a vote it's up
to you if you were too damn casual to
care and I don't believe that by the way
I think most people did feel very
strongly about exit or very strongly
about leave and
except one I lost get on with it
yeah what about all the pokies that were
told including 355 million million
pounds a week extra for the NHS both
sides I think both sides are educated I
mean what would happen if we didn't
remain in or what would happen if we
came at least I think they were
exaggerated but I remain convinced that
if you had a second referendum the
British people would say we've made that
decision stop messing us about I'm
actually against referendum on on
balance I think you should elect members
of parliament they should go to the
House of Commons they should listen to
all the arguments and they should make
the decisions I gonna have a referendum
every few weeks if you're not careful
this of course was a great and important
occasion okay we have the great
important occasion and we voted on it
what's of you on the way that David
Cameron dealt with that well I think the
sad thing about David Cameron's
Premiership is that it's now going to be
the only thing he's remembered for many
of the things he achieved during his
Premiership will be forgotten because
people only remember brexit I think
where it went wrong was not our end
those Europeans who didn't give him a
bit more who didn't say yes we can see
you're in trouble
Prime Minister and why don't we offer
you X Y and Zed and then you can go back
to the British people and they'll feel
better about remain you've got nothing
he came back with nothing and I repeat
the British people are not that stupid
they realized he'd come back with
nothing and it affected the vote so why
did he choose to have a referendum it
was because he was on the ropes from
people like Nigel Farage no nothing to
do with knives with branch it was to do
with the quite simply that he'd put it
in the party manifesto and having said
in the party manifesto
I will hold a referendum the British
people can decide he had no choice I
don't think Margaret Thatcher would ever
have putted anything John matric would
ever have put it in in the ref in
but once they had he was stuck
was he right to resign straightaway
would I like to be know was he right to
resign straightaway
yes yes that was the British people had
voted against what he advised the
British people had told him he was wrong
but he was they would have been a
horrible mess it would have been
impossible for him to continue in those
circumstances every time he rose at the
despatch box he would have been reminded
no I think he did the honorable thing I
think going was right what do you think
of Boris Johnson I think he's an amazing
personality he's clearly extremely
bright and lots of fun uh and long may
he stay that way because the last thing
the Conservative Party needs at the
moment is another election because if we
have another election I feel we have to
have a general election if we select a
leader who has never been voted for by
the British people I think it it would
be the right thing to hold a general
election and for that reason alone the
last thing the Conservative Party need
at the moment is a leadership election
I saw you be very grumpy on the TV this
morning so much you were very grumpy on
the TV with very grumpy with Suzanna my
friend this morning when she asked you
about what should happen as far as
Theresa may is concerned well I'm
actually far more interested in the deal
we'll get from Europe I'm interested in
what you think about Theresa may I know
where you're trying to get me to go no
point being grumpy with me I don't want
a leadership election and I think she
must be left as Prime Minister we will
know better we will have a better
opinion when we know what we've got out
of Europe and we know if the House of
Commons has voted for it and I'd like to
see a clear run until then and once
that's been decided we can all decide
whether she's a capable prime minister
or not do you think she is yes I do so
she should stay in
Oh almost certainly she should stay in
office I can't see someone who's so
obviously her successor that we should
all jump up and down with glee because
we found someone I answer that always
with the following I didn't know who
would be leader of the Conservative
Party
two weeks before Margaret Thatcher got
it I didn't know two weeks before John
major got it I didn't know two weeks
before Cameron got it I didn't know two
weeks before May got it so when it's two
weeks ago give me a quick get writer's
block
you're so prolific when it comes to
writing now I've been very lucky it's
it's weird because my home in Majorca is
called
writer's block but no it's never
happened maybe one day it will I confess
I never no more than three or four pages
ahead because I'm frightened if I know
too far ahead the reader will work out
what's going to happen but my son's
always a surprise to you with yes yes if
I don't know the end how can they never
the end and in fact the end of heads you
win whether they're all talking about
really did genuinely come with about 20
pages to go and I thought can I pull it
off will it work and wrote it and
realize they had to rewrite the whole
book to make the last 20 pages work wow
he was such a brilliant brilliant
storyteller and talked to us about the
lovely Mary she's now last time I saw
you was your Christmas party and she you
were not seeing that she was chairman as
a scientist she's been she's been
chairman science and museum for a couple
of years now and absolutely loving it
having been a scientist all her life
having taught at Oxford Cambridge and
London University before becoming
chairman of Commissioner versus hospital
Addenbrooke's and then she was invited
to be chairman of the Science Museum
I've never seen her happier and indeed
in our 50 years of marriage I've never
seen her more content I think probably
running a great hospital with 7,000
staff and 700 million budget is an
hour-by-hour worry there's only
news every day running the Science
Museum which is a great honor in
privilege I think's a bit easier than
running a national and NHS hospital I
think that's I met a man today who wants
to be chairman of a national I told him
it's not fun no she is a magnificent
woman with a brilliant brain it has to
be said can I talk to you about the
House of Lords which of course you are a
member of we saw last week that one of
your colleagues one of your peers if you
weren't in so many ways chose to out a
senior I'm picking my words very
carefully tiptoeing through the lawyers
Lorraine drops here a senior businessman
was that the correct place to out
someone who had a super injunction I
actually thought it was irresponsible I
think the law is the law and you have
the very finest lawyers in the country
deciding this and if you want to change
that law that is what Parliament is for
by all means change it so that if you
disagree with guiding orders or you
disagree with something bring in a new
law but I thought it was irresponsible
to think I am more important than any of
the Law Lords I know more than any of
the lawyers so I'm going to right over
their heads I thought that was wrong but
not this specific case but more
generally when people have got a lot of
money they use the opportunity with all
of that money to prevent publication in
newspapers in other words preventing the
Free Press that isn't acceptable that's
exactly that's you've hit it exactly K
that's the law that should be changed
that is where the change should be made
so then cannot be done but the Law Lords
and those who run our legal system they
can only stand by the law and it's
Parliament's responsibility to change
the law if that's wrong so yes I agree
with you we shouldn't have gagging
orders so change the law if you weren't
a writer great right
and a politician what would you well I'm
a natural captain of the England cricket
team I see that it's just that no one
has ever noticed that I've been aware of
my abilities it it may come from the
rather sad day that I was chosen in a
charity match to play for England
against the rest of the world and a very
great bowler whom many of your listeners
will remember a Derek Underwood bowled
me on the first ball and Ian both and
was the umpire so he shouted no ball and
the Eric Underwood was so cross he did
it again on the second ball and I swear
to you I never even saw the ball the
stumps just disappeared and then I
realized what it was like to face a
world-class Ebola and indeed although I
have been telling the nation for many
years I am the natural captain of the
England cricket team I have to admit you
were great sportsman though you were an
athlete with you I love running I would
like to have been born a cricketer but I
loved running and had very fancy days
running for my country yeah and an frogs
had enjoyed both but in my heart I want
to walk down those steps at Lord's onto
the ground I once did in another charity
match with Vivian Richards and I nearly
ran him out but I sacrificed my wicket
and as I returned to the pavilion and
climbed the steps a local Somerset man
looked at me and that are Geoffrey my
dear it was a good decision
the last stoning in Taunton was in 1472
head she witnessed that one heads you
win is out tomorrow and for me has been
such a challenge because the Clifton
Chronicles were seven books in a row and
writing an individual book for the first
time in ten years was one of the biggest
challenges I've had to face and I have
to say the press have been very generous
about in the critics and I'm one but
more important none of them have
revealed the ending